I'll take that one if you don't mind
so the our average restaurant does 2.7
million dollars it brings about 18
percent in store cash flow to the bottom
line we run about four percent overhead
so it's sort of a net margin 14 percent
that compares with a total development
cost of about 1.6 million dollars of
that you can borrow 1.3 so it's about a
1 it's about a 300,000 or equity
investment the debt service on 1.3 is
about $100,000 a year the cash flow
coming off the restaurant is about
$500,000 a year so it's literally about
$400,000 a year on a $300,000 investment
it is
I don't remember enough about stats to
answer that the way on something to do
with an R squared or something
but the range
so in our 87 units the lowest volume
unit breaks even at about 23,000 dollars
a week our highest volume unit does
almost a hundred thousand a week so it's
a great variation but I would say the
vast majority are in a tight band
between 45 and 55 so that when I build a
new unit I actually have great comfort
that our sales prediction is going to be
very close and we've never really been
wrong Applebee's and many concepts have
tremendous demographic and competitive
analysis tools that help you predict
sales volumes - so Applebee's actually
has tools to help you and your basically
your site selection important well and
people do so we find a site and you know
I like it but then I have to submit it
to them they summon someone ought to see
it goes to committee they have to
approve it they turn down sites all the
time okay
for the man the Mansoor talks but in a
service business as most service
covering there's there's a lot of
actually we have fairly high margins
once you know you've got to pay for rent
I mean we're talking about you know how
much we use the building it's always the
you know one of the key issues you've
got rent and you've got your fixed
managers there at that point you know
we're tutoring three kids and they're
paying us forty four dollars an hour and
we're paying a teacher $12 an hour
so each marginal child we get so once
you get above your breakeven and that's
that's the nut then it's a wealth or a
post fact I looked at the performance of
various kind of franchise you know
something you know it's small it's like
like what are they wenzels pretzels or
something all the way up to like you
know more traditional fast food
franchise like a Burger King and I mean
what you'll see is these guys are you
know gonna do sales anywhere between you
know 400 K to you know one and a half
million sort of an average and you have
certainly have you'll have superstar
stores that you really well and from
what I can tell the margins you know the
operating margins are typically no sorry
the the net margins are gonna be
somewhere if you rent it well you know
the 20 25 percent so I think the key as
I said earlier is is building a you know
is building a portfolio of these
businesses right because you just not
that they're necessary economies of
scale across the stores but I think the
economies of financing scale right I
mean as far as being able to lend money
and like I think about my stroll right
now I was a I'm basically for the equity
I plowed into my first store I'm seeing
you know we you know returns out the
Nexus 150 percent which exceeds what I
get in the stock market these days right
so you know take advantage of the
capital markets to really get in
but the challenge really is is getting a
bank to you know lend you that money
right because you know if I would go up
to a bank and and say you know I mean
there's another there's another sort of
concept I'm trying to roll out but you
know I want to open up make fifteen of
these things and you know it's
challenging right because I don't I
don't have the portfolio at this point
to be able to make it a no-brainer
decision so I mean there's a lot of
salesmanship that goes on to get that
off the ground how do we coming out of
school convince a bank to give us a dime
when it comes to franchising you guys
all had some experience pretty extensive
experience even if it wasn't directly
related to franchising you had sort of
an experience based on your resume that
they could go to and see you know buy
something that has a track record right
banks will loan against businesses with
you know track with improving cash flow
that's why when you say well we can't
start out this way I think it's perfect
I think the best opportunity of
franchising is to find a group of you
know five units ten units you know buy
it and you can borrow 70% and you can
raise from friends and family the
balance you know and pay them back with
a good return and then you're in
business in skill and there are many
many maturing franchisees you know they
got into the good systems you know in
the 70s and 80s and they're retiring and
they're gonna sell so it's great for
them because they can be used underlying
business as a collateral and so
basically you just have to throw off you
know carve out some chunk of your cash
flow to them to service the debt and and
then pay it off that way so for existing
franchise that's a very common approach
and if you wanna be something from
scratch yeah the SBA is also available
and that's another sort of Vantage of a
franchise is that because it tends is a
proven concept and there's typically
system-wide you know set of data for
them to get comfortable around you know
I have seen SBA extend loans for brand
new stores if you do go to new franchise
it has a pretty for a predictable cash
flow
and the unfortunate SP has lowered their
limits this year I think it's down to
$700,000 it used to be a 1.3 million but
but still it's definitely enough to get
started on your first one then basically
the multiplier effect you know basically
plan on building out you know a couple
more per year every year for the next
ten years and then then you'll be like
this guy right here
no no I mean pay but there's a
difference between what you need to show
to get started and what it actually cost
to build out so I mean in this area is
probably gonna run you about 350
actually to do the initial build out of
the store but you know if you're smart
about it you can do that with zero of
your money right we could actually walk
through offline all of the all of the
steps but yeah you typically are paying
a franchise fee up front but there's
thirty five thousand appellees what is
it kept this is your first one is it's
thirty five and then as you build out
more there is a sliding scale but then
the rest of that those cost you don't
incur dependence or arrangement you have
with with the tenant of your space as
well as your general contract but
they're gonna typically demand the 50%
up front and then you know then you buy
all the equipment's were later on in the
development process but you got line up
the money up front otherwise no one's
gonna build anything for you yeah
question so you enjoy this thing so much
and your back and work like punching the
clock working for the man what was it
that made you not want to go open up on
you're gonna be different
franchisor maybe go do something
completely different other than the
clothes don't you kind of guys I think
some of them are here today so no but uh
but I don't I don't think what you
described is mutually exclusive so the
fact of the matter is and I've made no
secret about it there are other projects
that I'm pursuing I think from where I
am right now
having you know basically plowed my own
money into the first one and now you
know levering myself as much as I can
to build out my next two short of
actually going out there and in raising
a syndicate which you know I've
considered doing there's not much more I
can do in parallel right so which is not
to suggest that when I've dealt with my
build outs of additional stores that
you know quit my job and focus on that
but what I what I've learned is if you
know you there's no shortage of people
out there who want to get in on the
ground floor right and so you can
actually find people to work with you
and and basically you know you know you
can you know lever these people to help
you either build out additional stores
or pursue entirely new concepts so you
can do both and so the reality is the
only reason I'm working right now is I
really needed something to keep me you
know challenged and stimulated convinced
the franchisor to go ahead personal on a
capital we may need to get started and a
minimal scaling and even one of these
franchises to get going at a decent
level or we can operate you accepted I
think it varies you have to show liquid
assets you know technically of half a
million dollars to qualify as an
appellee franchisee in reality dharna
markets left I mean for all the big
concepts there are no you can't sign up
and just start looking for a location
and the younger concepts you can but I
mean you have to understand there's a
night-and-day risk difference between
cold stone and McConnell's at this point
so I don't know if there's really a good
answer that any cold stone now what did
you have to show then they all have them
and they publish them this is all public
you know domain I don't know if there's
a threat what I need to show but but I
mean I have the cash to do it so there's
something called a uniform franchise
offering circular ufoc
and this is regulated offering right so
they must state what the minimum liquid
you know require me of to show they have
to stay what the royalty is and what the
whole deal is up front
and you can get these things probably
just off the web aren't the only
franchised industry and you talked about
curves earlier just as an example of the
exact opposite it costs $20,000 because
less than $40,000 all in including the
build-out to open the curves as a
franchisee and curves actually is not
it's pretty much done in the US that got
6,000 units in eight years but you know
40,000 dollars to get in and typical
curves back to your question about
numbers will do somewhere between 150
and 200 thousand top line so it's not as
big a business as you guys have and
it'll throw off fifty to sixty thousand
in cash flow I mean that's a great
investment it's also riding a big wave
right now we had actually called them to
see if they'd send somebody and
unfortunately we couldn't cuz I tried to
be an interesting one particularly given
the increasing interest
I look at things as mundane as and
there's a post caution but as mundane as
coin up laundry laundromats right and
those things are cash cows right I mean
you just find the right unfortunate
demarcus reasonably saturated but you
know each one of those things is a jet
you know throw off fifty sixty thousand
dollars pure cash right and and all you
really need to do is then they've every
night go in there with your bucket or
your barrel very low maintenance and and
gas stations are another business set
that I've looked into I mean there are a
number of things out there they don't
have restaurant businesses you know can
be a lot of hard is a lot harder than a
lot of the other businesses out there
you know I mean if you're looking at
businesses definitely open up your
risers I mean you know there are a
number of other great sort of you know
retail non restaurant concepts out there
out there that can do really well and
just a matter of I think a large part
was getting the right location and Billy
not enough of these things where they
throw off enough cash where you can live
the life that you want or keep a bind I
mean it's one of the scale economies the
greater valgus you doing - any one unit
you know you're just flowing how much
more of the bottom line because it takes
not much more to build an Applebee's in
terms of the time that it takes probably
to open a new cold stone
right so but you know you end up doing
much greater volumes at the end of the
day my advice to anyone is go for volume
volume volume volume the highest volume
concept you can get your hand on but if
you're buying smaller number how dirty
can we expect to get your hands in the
day-to-day operations of the business if
you're buying gas stations are you gonna
be spending time behind the counter in
the gas station or can you completely
you know hire people to take care of I
just may be a dumb question I just don't
have any sense of if you're scooping ice
cream I mean the answer that's pretty
clear I mean if you're gonna get into
any business you absolutely positively
need to make a commitment to roll up
your sleeves and getting into that store
right because I mean you know and of
course I have a very different set of
circumstances than my other panelists
but but you know my philosophy around
this is well one is your baby right so
you want to make sure you you know it
gets run and think you have the way you
want it but my philosophy run around
building these things is you know how
can you possibly hire and train people
to run this thing if you yourself don't
know firsthand what's the best way that
these things should be managed and so if
you if you look at it purely as an
investment play then I would say I would
be you'll be cautious because you know
like like the chain of Applebee's that
you know we're brought up it's a know
those are all breakeven you know stores
the guy was in Chicago you know running
it like a you know a portfolio of
investments and you know you got to
really make the effort to not only from
day one you know learn and you know
nothing I think we presses my kids more
than when I'm on the you know in the
early days of the store I was in there
you know closing up the store mopping it
up sticking my hand down the drain and
pulling all this gunk out of there you
know they look at that and say you know
if the if the owner of the store you
know an MBA from Stanford is doing that
then you know I should be able to do it
too and so that's the kind of example
you need to set I'm not only among you
know when you're first in there but also
with all the people that you're all the
managers and regional managers that
you're hiring to take care of the
businesses setting up your organization
structure until you get to a certain
scale you've got a whole business you've
got one two three or four
or the manager that entity doesn't come
in who does I mean I guess it's
something to be gas does pump itself now
but but you know Lars II you're gonna be
the one showing up there nobody else
does so you better know how to do it I
would say that I mean the operator who
built all those restaurants and was
running them at the time is still
running them and what I did was you know
look and he's a veteran from you know
early days valve he's a great guy but he
was a frustrated executive slash
entrepreneur reporting to someone far
away he didn't understand the unique
environment in Washington yeah I
basically said to him
what I'm gonna do I don't want to run it
day-to-day I have are you qualified I
don't know how to run a restaurant and I
want you to run it and I'm going to
interest you in running it and I gave
him an equity participation which for
him was very meaningful and that's path
to success
3/4 I it's impossible to say at the same
time you know I think we hit scale and
at the same time
Applebee's introduced national
advertising you know the Washington
market had always bought local radio is
too expensive by TV up there so a
national hit TV that helped it's all
these things came together to really
make it you know I it's better to be
lucky than smart I think we were in many
ways just lucky but but you may go in
luck
do you think back is that an overall
strategy of getting into French as you
say you're gonna buy into the franchise
thank you try and buy is it it's a good
strategy trend by underperforming stores
or corporate stores likely to be
underperforming stores because they're
just less interested in the outcome I
think in principle that sounds like
doesn't sound like a bad approach but be
careful right because when you look at
the you'll I mean you have to look at
the financials right of any store that
you're looking at by but if it's
underperforming I mean there are
multiple reasons why it could be
underperforming right so clearly if you
can pinpoint that it's truly operational
which I didn't necessarily do but I just
knew I mean we the the center structure
wasn't there for a corporate you know
manager in my store to run that as
efficiently and smartly you know as
someone as a no local owner operator but
there are other reason I mean there are
Colson's out in the system that that
perform poorly not because of poor
operational oversight but because they
just pick stupid locations right and so
you know make sure you look carefully at
wire stores underperforming they look at
the trade area talk to other franchisees
and develop a sense of whether or not
you should be able to improve that store
but the great thing is if you do find an
underperforming store you'll probably
find that the owner will will sell that
at a discount because you basically I
mean I tend to value these things
anywhere from three to five times II bit
dot right and so your chances are you
know an underperforming store you'll be
able to buy for a song right and you
know be able to you know flip that thing
in a year for a profit if you want to or
leverage that and build out more it can
be a great approach
but if by any chance into folks this
through have a little bit of an ego
which never happens here it's a very
good negotiating ploy that people used
on me and then I use on the people
subsequently is oh yeah I'm stupid I
can't run it and you just think yeah I'm
like ten times better than this guy and
you know then I used the same thing when
I sold mine and I don't know education
six months later they came back said
well guys she sort of did everything
right I don't know what but so you know
in a negotiation it's a very easy thing
to do yeah you you're gonna be better
you're gonna be the person to turn this
restaurant around that's had five
failures before
so just be a little careful about that I
think Jim makes a very good point about
there's sort of an inherent advantage an
owner/operator has because they sort of
care more because the other management
was working for the man they're not
really caring however you shouldn't
underestimate that there are great
management structures out there that
could be running it perfectly well if
we've done multiple acquisitions across
the country at this point it's taught me
anything by the best quality you can get
your hands on
do not look for underperforming stores
go the opposite way and pay up for the
best structure your life will be easier
right you know and just build off that
success you know find a good market and
then build one more in it right and turn
around you know you get what you pay for
in life the price of these seemed very
low it seems like such an incredible
opportunity you know I think it's
because it's a restaurant business and
it suffers from the extreme risk of the
industry and it's a very limited you
know market of people who can arrange
the capital to go into such a perceived
risky Enterprise in fact it's not that
risky and it's part of the whole
arbitrage opportunity if there's a scale
of risk from you know zero to 100 and
100 is risky you know I think Applebee's
is really close to zero right but the
entire band of multiple is three to six
right or you know doing it like that and
really it ought to be you know sort of 1
to 15 or something like that but it's
not and as a buyer you don't care you
care about the difference between that
and debt
do you have it like a tricky experience
either success or failure in terms of
dealing with the franchisor in terms
evaluating them deal with them before
buying the franchise talk to their
fantasies and fly out and see him
whatever that did you apply it and see
the cold where are the cold some people
Arizona so yeah I mean yeah yeah I hear
different stories across different
franchise doors but you know I think
what you'll find is he exactly like Greg
said if you talk to the franchisees
you'll develop a sense of how supportive
and how strong the franchisor is and how
much they really care about the
franchisee I actually was awarded
another ice cream franchise from a
competitor and before I got my cold
stone right and so but I you know I
talked to a number of people had
franchises but for these guys and he
just realized that they weren't getting
the kind of support or commitment or
sort of you know didn't have the quite a
vision that Coulson had and so I pass on
that I know you know not knowing that I
would ever get a call to him but the
greatest point I mean I I kind of
singled out what I thought was sort of
the highest quality
you know franchise and and I decided if
I wasn't going to get you know the
highest quality ice cream that I would
go ahead and get something else in the
documents that Greg referred to there's
a listing of all the franchises
nationally so even though the
corporation might give you a couple
there dog-and-pony franchisees go
through and call throughout the country
nobody's people are very unsure about
sharing their disappointment talk your
ear off yeah
so no call the guy the Bangor Maine to
you know Miami Florida to San Diego and
also if you think the demographics are
gonna be more similar you know talk to
somebody else in coastal California
might be more applicable depending on
the franchise and somebody in Des Moines
but you know talk to those folks and
they'll give you the
anyhow last words of wisdom no I mean
the only thing I mean I'm so close by I
mean you know I've tried to get some ice
cream
no but but I've tried to be a sort of
you know
accessible and receptive towards people
in the GSB community so you know if you
have questions or want to talk more you
know feel free to drop me a line any
time